[Música]
en la misión de hoy de directo américa
edición nocturna tendremos una edición
especial de nuestra crónica de historia
a propósito de la muerte de mijail
gorbachov y por ello le doy la
bienvenida al estudio a mi compañero
álvaro cordero álvaro la muerte del ex
presidente soviético mijail gorbachov ha
desatado una ola de reacciones
internacionales cuál es la importancia
histórica de este personaje buenas
noches andrés bueno pues cuando hablamos
de mijail gorbachov estamos hablando
seguramente de una de las figuras
políticas más importantes en la segunda
mitad del siglo 20 gorbachov llegó al
poder en la unión soviética en 1985 y
fue parte de una corriente reformista
que trató de modernizar a la unión
soviética tras décadas de inmovilismo
este político era un soplo de aire
fresco para una nación que no atravesaba
su mejor momento y que se sumergía en
una profunda crisis pero a pesar de sus
intenciones de finalizar la guerra fría
en buenos términos con eeuu sin que ello
significará el final del socialismo
fracasó y fue el último mandatario que
tuvo la unión soviética andrés álvaro
cuáles fueron las reformas que impulsó
gorbachov pues las principales reformas
fueron dos
y también el grass not la prehistórica
significa algo así como reestructuración
y glasnost in significa transparencia o
apertura estos conceptos fueron desde un
inicio un tanto ambiguos y ni siquiera
el propio gorbachov era consciente de
las consecuencias que tendría su
aplicación la perestroika se convirtió
en el gran plan de modernización
económica una apuesta que trajo una
serie de medidas económicas como la
normalización del mercado de consumo la
lucha contra la corrupción o la
privatización de empresas y el glasnost
por su parte fue la apuesta por la
apertura política de un sistema que
durante décadas había estado regido
única y exclusivamente por el partido
comunista algo que permitió por primera
vez la libre expresión de opiniones
incluidas las críticas al poder central
así hablaba a gorbachov sobre el
desarrollo de la perestroika
necesitamos más emprendimiento más
democracia más organización y
disciplinas entonces podremos llevar a
la perestroika a toda velocidad y dar un
nuevo impulso al desarrollo del
socialismo socialismo álvaro ya esta
reforma supusieron alguna mejora la
situación de la unión soviética pues la
realidad es que no de hecho pasó todo lo
contrario la unión soviética no estaba
preparada a estas alturas para superar
el shock tan grande que supone para una
nación que tras décadas de economía
planificada se abra el mercado además
las presiones que recibió gorbachov por
sus reformas fueron muy elevadas por un
lado un sector importante del partido
comunista y de la caja de consideraban
que este tipo de medidas traerían el
final irremediable del sistema
socialista y de la unión soviética algo
que él mismo gorbachov tampoco quería y
por el otro una serie de intelectuales y
sectores más pro occidentales empezaron
a criticar la lentitud de las reformas
de gorbachov gracias a la libertad
política que empezó a ver por el
glasnost una situación que obviamente
trajo una gran inestabilidad a todas y
una profunda crisis económica que
traería consecuencias muy importantes
pero a pesar de estos problemas de
álvaro su popularidad falta no pues sí y
no en el panorama internacional ganó una
gran reputación gracias a que promulgó
un acercamiento con eeuu con el objetivo
de poner punto final a la guerra fría
por medio de acuerdos de no
proliferación de armas nucleares y de
cooperación además sacó en 1988 a las
tropas de afganistán una guerra que
estaba desangrando a la urss desde 1978
en términos humanos y económicos gestos
que le hicieron ganar el nobel de paz en
1990 sin embargo en el panorama político
interno su popularidad cayó en picado y
la crisis económica motivó una serie de
movimientos contrarios al partido
comunista tanto fuera como dentro de la
unión soviética que a la larga supondría
su final y finalmente álvaro que
catapultó su final pues su final fue en
el año 1991 varios años de desgaste
hicieron que su figura quedara relegada
a un segundo plano en favor de políticos
que si apostaban un cambio más fuerte
como boris yeltsin en agosto de ese año
el sector más duro del partido comunista
y la caja dio un golpe de estado para
deponerlo del poder y restablecer el
sistema socialista tradicional para
salvar a la unión soviética y aunque
sobrevivió al golpe su reputación quedó
seriamente dañada la urss fue
desintegrándose en varias repúblicas
hasta que dimitió el 25 de diciembre de
si la reflexión en esta situación que
sigue el establecimiento de la comunidad
de estados independientes de sudar se
dejó de actuar como presidente de la
unión soviética un apuesto principiante
eso es cero estas palabras también
fueron el final de la unión soviética
tras ello rusia continuó con una
profunda crisis económica y recesión que
golpeó muy fuerte a toda la población
durante la década de 1990 y gorbachov se
mantuvo como una figura altamente
impopular entre los ciudadanos
álvaro cordero nuestro cronista de
historia en flash 24 gracias por
traernos este relato sobre el legado de
mijail gorbachov que recordemos murió
hoy a los 91 años seguimos con más aquí
en directo américa